this what a monday night it
was christopher hello sometimes
when you wait and you wait
and you wait you get one of those nights
that you will never forget and that's
what we got last night the cap week 14
of the 2020 season
congratulations to the nfl for getting
14 weeks in congratulations to everyone
involved for giving us a game
that was the most entertaining regular
season game
since rams chiefs november 19 of 2018
period 54-51 then 47-42
now and you could argue that this one
was even more
dramatic and exciting when you throw in
the
why was lamar jackson in the locker room
for so long question which we will
delve into today but the first thing i
want to say after i say hello to our
peacock audience siriusxm211 nbc
sports audio nbcsn
sky sports nfl for our friends in the uk
and ireland anybody listening on a
podcast and now i've said that
i can say this chris yes
i'm waiting for the
hue and cry from the people who will say
that last night's game
set back defensive football for 50 years
because we heard
some of that after rams chiefs yeah and
to all those people
i just want to preemptively say sit down
and shut up no no
because 89 points look until
until it gets like basketball and
there's a presumption you're gonna score
every time you have the ball and
football at the nfl level hasn't gotten
to that point yet
there isn't a presumption you're going
to score last night
it was exciting because they kept
scoring and scoring and scoring
especially late
but there still isn't in the nfl this
idea like arena football
that hey you get the ball you score
other team gets the ball scores let's
see if somebody can get lucky and make a
stop that sounds horrible
go ahead right and and if we get there
i'll let you know
right we're not there no we're not
nobody ever talks about a 6-3 game that
was a defensive struggle
all morning long and all day long so i
just want to plant that flag early
i don't want to hear although i can't
stop anyone from saying it i'm not going
to listen to anyone who says
this game sets back the game of football
it doesn't
where did you get this from who's
partying what got you
all on this conversation on a tuesday i
just
i just remember from two years ago yes
that that was the narrative after rams
chiefs right oh my god
we've set back defensive football by x
number of years
no we've made the game more exciting
people are drawn
in this is what people want to watch
especially as the nfl
begins to fully appreciate the long-term
benefits of legalized wagering because
there ain't nobody
that's going to be betting money on
defensive play
they're betting money on points points
points points points so anyway i just
wanted to get that off my chest
because i i'm just trying to i'm trying
to cauterize that argument
before it goes any farther last night
was awesome
last night was special and uh there's
there's so much well i think we've
budgeted the first hour of the program
just to talk about this game chris
there's so much to talk about yeah well
there is and you know like just to get
out
ahead of your conversation there it is
different to me than the chiefs rams
football game
you know that game that that had moments
and plays of like
oh there's a guy catching the ball
nobody's in the screen
touchdown and then it was like three
plays later the other team answers
nobody's in the screen touchdown this
was at least sustained
drive smash mouth football at times yes
it led to some big plays
and it led to you know two teams
answering each other a bunch here
throughout the football game but
i i didn't have as much of a i didn't
have a problem with that is what i'm
saying and i you know me i'm a fan of
the 2824
football game that's my favorite type of
game but this was fun to watch
had a little bit of everything still had
hard-hitting defensive plays
but oh my gosh and i don't know where do
you want to start with
cramps bathroom what let's talk about
let's just let's just summarize some of
the weirdness and i'll agree with you my
favorite scores are in the 30s
i'll take a 41 38 44 38 i'll live with
a periodic 4742 which by the way was the
first time in the history
of the nfl that a final
score was 47.42 never happened before
i'll take another one
anytime especially in prime time the
other oddity from last night baker
mayfield browns quarterback first
quarterback in nfl history to lose two
games while scoring 42
points they had a 45-42 loss i believe
when he was a rookie
and it was only the second safety last
night the ultimate bad beat with the
ravens winning by three giving three
points
it was a push everyone gets their ticket
back they get their refund nobody wins
nobody loses
until the browns do the band is on the
field and they keep going backward and
it's funny because
there was a point where no one could
find a teammate to lateral the ball
they're all too tired to run behind
where the guy with the ball was until
somebody ran into the end zone ball gets
thrown in it's a safety
and it's 47-42 and the ravens cover
which was good for us because i think we
both picked ravens to win and ravens to
cover i haven't gone back and checked
our scores
but ravens win ravens cover
just like that just just easy like crazy
they did it the easy way well it was
just
and that doesn't even we didn't even
have room on the graphic for
lamar jackson's bout with
cramps it was cramps okay
all right so let's just start there
first off how amazing that was because i
i mean i have friends texting me too
last night like
i mean what the heck now he just comes
back and he's okay
well yes that that's how it works just
so we can clarify this
first off the guys in my history of the
nfl
you know major college football
university of texas
you know this we've talked about it
before but those
the guys that cramp are the freakiest
guys on the team it's it's the freaky
athletes it's
you know it's the julio jones the
odell's the jalen ramseys it's the guys
that have
three percent body fat and they're all
muscle and explosion and everything like
that and it's just the wrong night of
what
whatever it is too much running didn't
hydrate enough whatever it is
either way he had to go in and get an iv
you saw that he was taped up around his
left arm right there around his elbow
that's where they stick the needle in
and i don't know i mean i haven't heard
his post-game press conference mike
but i will say he was in there longer
than you
normally see somebody get an iv it makes
me wonder if it was like a more of a
severe case of cramps
maybe than you usually get as a as an
athlete but this is not
that uncommon for an athlete like lamar
jackson and
wow good thing he got back just in a
flash of time
i i look it's funny
yeah and it's different and it's just
the ultimate
confluence of sports and social media
yes it is that the moment he left and i
think it reinforced it for a lot of
people when you saw him making the move
to the locker room and trying to hurry
in
that was something we've all experienced
at some time in our lives that was the
i gotta go get out of well you're right
and he had a little
shrimp he had a little shimmy too but
it's because of the crabs like he's
probably got his i know
i know yeah yeah but go ahead guys i
know but but when but when you
see that you think been there
done that yeah right so that's what
fueled
this this this frenzy that lamar
jackson i don't know what the
appropriate terminology is for
seven in the morning in the east and
eventually prime time in the uk
but he had an impending intestinal
requirement
right that is i think what i'm going to
go with and not the seinfeld and
uh i i it and and i agree with you
listen we've been there and done that
and it doesn't take that long that's the
other reality that's right and
and lamar it got and my son said to me
we were watching the game and he said
you know lamar's going to go turn his
phone on and he's going to see that
everybody is talking about how he had to
go poop right and
and yes he found out and he reached he
responded
with one of the one of the memes that's
out there of a little kid looking under
the bottom of a stall
saying that's john harbaugh telling are
you ready yet hurry up
yeah hurry and and lamar retweets it
what's the quote on the tweet y'all
tripping i wasn't
i wasn't taking a poop although he used
the little emoji the little
the little the little chocolate frozen
yogurt emoji uh which many thought that
was initially appealing so
uh yeah enjoy your breakfast um so
anyway chris
that's i and and i agree with you and
and unless
it was next level brilliance to put the
the bandage on the arm where the iv was
then yeah that he got an iv yes period
here's my question for you though right
we usually see guys get ivs when it's
hot
it wasn't hot last night no how do you
cramp up on a night when it's not hot
well you're still running around
intensities high
and he was running around a lot i mean
as we saw
there was all over the football field so
and
hey listen we can we do we gotta we
can't forget
i i don't know he he did just have
covered 19.
you know he talked about his body
adjusting through that and it didn't
feel quite normal until the last few
days
so he's probably not like tip top 100
endurance muscle shape right now to
where he was before he got that
so it's probably a little bit of both
and all that kind of combining
a little bit of a you know i'm guessing
that's what it is
that that's to me what it would be but
yeah that combined with the running
uh it doesn't matter if it's cold or not
i've seen those those type of athletes
those guys that are freaky fast and
got no body fat they can cramp in those
settings just as easily as they can on a
really hot day
let's hear from the man himself on
the wrinkle that made last night's
finish
even more dramatic here's lamar jackson
like right before those two passes i
throw to willy and mark the overthrows i
was cramping my phone
and i'm telling coach i'm like man i
need to get some salt in my system real
quick
and you know we putting the ball i'm on
the sideline we end up
tightening up catching the pick on the
interception we go down the score and
right after that
i get the ball to jk and my legs just
start cramping i'm like
bro like i need something now like to
help me get better real quick because
this is a crucial game right here you
know
both teams you playing their hearts off
and we went to the back um dr tuck she
was
helping me out a lot um and kev came
back started scratching me
and you know tracy was doing a great job
dropping the ball down the field
then i see my goggle down and as as i'm
seeing him go down like
i'm still stretching like i'm like i
gotta get i'm catching an attitude
because i'm like man it ain't going
anywhere we want to
and then i see him go down and i'm like
we gotta start man like we just gotta go
out there
and i start running out there kel
running with me it's fourth down
and off this line brought they blocked
the tail off and our guys just made
great catches and we came out the
victory
that's what made the entire
episode so memorable trace mcsorley goes
down
on that very well manicured knot
field at first energy stadium and you
see lamar jackson
coming back to the field fourth and five
straight onto the field
and not just runs for a first down
because i'm thinking he's going to run
he's going to get
it i saw it like an avenue over to his
left like i i i
he's going to get it he's going to run
to his left he's going to get the first
down we're going to keep going no he
throws the ball
two of all people mr drop
for the baltimore ravens right marquise
hollywood brown
and he catches it uses one of the deep
officials as a little bit of a screen
and gets into the end zone it was
amazing
you come back in one play you're down 35
34 you come back in one play
and with the two-point conversion which
took a big collision right before the
goal line to go in you're up 42-35
that that is the thing that took a great
game
and moved it into that level of that
handful of
of all time great regular season games
that you'll never forget yeah right well
it just has that that special moment
there
you know like you know the old willis
reed new york knicks moment or whatever
you want to talk about
you know two things first off you talked
about the field where you made fun of it
that probably didn't help his cramping
too you know him just trying to
you know really having to grip the
ground do whatever that is there but
they didn't have the right cleats on
either
that that's partly their fault too good
thing he adjusted there
like what i don't get is
is he gonna get out all right so first
off the cramps must have been serious
because
your arm cramping and things like that
that's a little bit more than
just hey your hamstring your calf muscle
when you start i i mean honestly i i
haven't heard of arm cramping too much
really you know that would be crazy hot
days so that just tells you
his body was not at a total 100
functioning state or in shape or
whatever
but to have those type of issues but
does he get on the field mike
like if mcsorley doesn't get hurt does
he get out there
and and save the day
or does the fourth down just flaunder
flounder if mcsorley doesn't get hurt
and they lose the game
that's where i'm really intrigued like
him getting hurt
actually saved the ravens butts to give
him the time to run out there and then
go okay i'm gonna play let me give him
the ball fourth down let's go
in his interview after the game with
lisa salters of espn
i got the distinct impression he was
coming back no matter what
trace mcsorley injured or not he was
coming back i just think seeing trace
mcsorley go down on that well-manicured
field
is what caused lamar jackson yeah
right now we're going right now but but
even then
when he saw because i mean the whole
thing the starting of the play looked
like it was going to go somewhere
right but he still i mean he knew the
clock was ticking generally but the guy
gets injured that was the
the final catalyst but i think he was
coming anyway
well i know i i mean i i would think he
was coming anyways
like you're right it just i don't know
if he gets there mcsorley doesn't get
hurt what if mcsorley gets up right
after that play gets in the huddle it's
fourth down they call a play and
oh man he missed another slant you know
or missed something to hollywood brown
hey game over
and then what like lamar runs out i was
like oh hey give me the ball one more
time let me show you
yeah i mean that just that's what's
fascinating i don't know if that's luck
or whatever but to me uh i was amazed by
that let alone
his whole performance last night i mean
that was insane
that was insane he here's what here's
what i was
astounded by 124 rushing yards was the
most ever in monday night football
history how could there not have been
more at some point
with mike vick right with lamar jackson
the night that he shredded the rams last
year i just would have assumed he had
150 rushing yards in that game so i was
i was blown away by that on that last
play too and and chris this goes back to
a conversation we have from time to time
when you draw it up on the board
the x handles the o but you know anthony
barr would tell us differently from a
couple of years ago against the rams
and last night olivier vernon you don't
you don't have him covering
out in the flat i understand the benefit
of fooling a quarterback
into who's covering and who's rushing
and we saw the ravens make an
interception with a move like that
but it's got to be quick you can't have
the guy trying to cover down field
and uh not a good idea to have olivier
vernon
drop into coverage and try to slow down
a guy like marquis brown
well it's he collides with mj stewart
right the the guy covering hollywood
brown there too
you know i think olivier vernon's trying
to
pursue lamar jackson or at least be
there
for him to take off do something like
that
and within that runs right into the guy
covering
hollywood brown and hollywood brown you
know if you go back to those pictures we
showed a minute ago look
there he's he's fighting to get off of
you know
bump coverage and that sorry that's
mitchell not not mj stewart i was wrong
but either way you know i think it's a
jam by olivier vernon
now let me get there and get in the way
or pursue lamar jackson and he obviously
picks off terence mitchell but the thing
that was amazing more than anything mike
is like you said it looked like he could
have probably ran for the first down
it was him one-on-one with another
player and it also looked like he had a
guy that
short where he probably could have just
thrown it to him and got the first down
when he left the ball deep i was like oh
no like just run whatever and then you
know of course you see hollywood brown
wide open easy touchdown but
just amazing the theatrics uh everything
about it
the performance by him was off the
charts good
like that was amazing what we saw last
night
i i come away from that game mike and i
don't go oh man baltimore's back
i come away going i'm more concerned
than ever with baltimore
i mean what's there to really look at
with baltimore last night and go
that was good i mean they really didn't
run the ball
that great and when i mean run the ball
i mean smash mouth
move people out of the way like that no
they ran the ball because they got
superman at quarterback
that's why they ran the ball it wasn't
because they physically dominated the
line of scrimmage or anything like that
they ran it because i mean a lot of
those running plays came on drop back
passes right mike
he drops back he kind of extends to play
finds elaine and zoom he's gone but he
was the whole team last night
defense not good i mean there's really
nothing to look at from the raven
standpoint for me to go
oh man the ravens are back on track this
looks good i mean
i really almost feel the the opposite i
almost feel like yeah the ravens won
that's great i'm glad they're still in
it
and he's amazing lamar and i want to
keep watching them play
but the way i feel about the two teams
the team that won
i feel lesser about than the team that
lost
uh i don't know if that well hang on
hang on though hang on though yeah they
still got 100 plus rushing yards out of
jk dobbins and gus
edwards combined they were they weren't
moving the ball
in chunks not big chunks but they were
moving at four or five yards at a clip
edwards averaged seven yards of carrying
dobbins average 4.1
but you know early on it felt like the
ravens were sluggish and it wasn't until
you start seeing lamar jackson
find the groove right and and and and
just be
dominant he had the touchdown run where
he was shot out of a cannon
and that's when you're thinking hey you
know what i'm i've i've
i've got it here i can you know i i i
the the ravens will be fine when you see
lamar jackson do that and they had
two touchdown lead at different
stretches of the game that's just
part of the setup for what what made it
all so memorable at the end of the day
and we'll be talking about the browns
coming up but
you know they they didn't go away after
this
willis reed paul pierce type moment
yeah at uh at at the two minute warning
that put the ravens up seven
they kept pushing and unfortunately they
left too much time on the clock for the
ravens
with lamar jackson to do it again and it
felt so inevitable
that lamar jackson number one was going
to get them into field goal range
and number two no matter how far that
field goal attempt
was justin tucker was going to make it
well
that i will say yeah i felt pretty good
like you get in range this guy is going
to knock it in
you know as far as the the time is
concerned
man that that you know that's a tough
one you got to go down you got to score
you know you're playing the baltimore
ravens we know that they're not the
greatest pass offense in the world
either
but hey well you know kareem hunt they
made big plays
when it was a fast drive sometimes you
just get a little unlucky that way i
don't know what uh what else to say
there but
it's not the type of situation where you
go down or something at the one yard
line right and go oh we'll just punch it
in the next play well you might not get
in at all and then you don't
you know tie the game or whatever so you
know
tough spot for them but the fact that
they were just gashing the the
ravens defense so consistently you know
that led them scoring them yeah maybe a
little quicker than they probably would
have liked
but mike like the other thing too with
the ravens the run game all that
yeah the run game only started to work
because lamar
wore the defense out because they were
chasing them around all over the field
for you know
two and a half quarters and then they
finally get it going
you know so to me that's where it's a
little bit more concerning than it's
just like oh it started out the game
and they just started moving people
cleveland moved people from the start
and they consistently dominated the line
of scrimmage i didn't feel the same way
with baltimore on the offensive side of
the ball
so it's just it's a different team with
them this year they're not as dominant
they're not as consistent
i'm glad they found a way to win but you
know like i said i guess i just
don't feel quite as happy or strong
about their football team and
i liked a lot of what i saw out of
cleveland even though they lost last
night
what a difference too from week one to
week 14. and jarvis landry told me a
couple of weeks ago
that hey look let's be realistic the
browns didn't have the benefit of not
season program with a new
coach a new playbook a new everything
and the ravens were just picking up
where they left off they had everybody
back they didn't lose either their
coordinators even though there was head
coaching buzz for both
greg roman and wink martindale last year
at this time
everybody was back it was easier for
them to start up the engine again
and that game got away from the browns
quickly and easily to get to 38 to six
and
and last night and and again i'm trying
to push as much
because there's a lot to say about
cleveland i don't want to make short
shrift of it
the browns need to be very proud of what
they did but the ravens and
ultimately the reason i picked the
ravens to win last night they
were the more desperate team and we saw
that desperation come through that's
something else lamar jackson said to
lisa saunders
the season's on the line it's winner go
home for us at this point i had to come
back
no you're yes they had all those aspects
the personal emotions
everything like that you would think
would favor them
and especially you play into the fact
where you just think
well cleveland's happy they're nine and
three they're not going to be as edgy
and you know on their game and and yeah
like the the desperate
emotion like baltimore but cleveland as
you can see
is is relishing the fact that they're
nine and three or we're nine and three
and now they're nine and four
but they're relishing it and they're not
looking at it like oh we could take it
we could take a deep breath we've stung
for so long and now we're good we
finally made it
who cares how it all ends up the rest of
the season no i think they look at it
like
hey we got momentum we're kind of good
and we can be a player in this thing
and you know kudos to them really i mean
baker mayfield and company answered the
bell
every time last night and made big plays
did
everything right other than his pick six
and even after that
he reacted great and brought the team
right back didn't even blink
so you know like you said there's a lot
to be proud of in cleveland
remember remember it wasn't a pick six
they weren't going oh yeah when they
scored that's right that's right
they were going for six right thank you
you mentioned you mentioned the issue
with the cleats yeah
and that's that's one thing that i think
is going to get lost in the shuffle
because the second half ended up being
so memorable but
it was amazing to me it took so long
for them to get lamar jackson to change
his shoes there was one point
where they were carrying on the sideline
the seven stud cleats and they created
the impression
that he had changed them but it was
obvious the shoes
that were that were being displayed in
the sidelines shot
were were different from the ones that
he had on for the entirety the first
half it wasn't until the second half
that we saw that he had put on different
cleats yeah it it
it's important and you know the the
ground
and cleats can that that whole
conversation could change as the game
goes on
it can so you could go out during
warm-ups and maybe it's not quite as
cold
and the field you know is what had
looked like it had short grass and it
it did look pretty well manicured i
can't say that i looked like
issues with the grass but i've been in
this situation too before where
yeah the grass is good everything's good
in warm-ups but
as the night goes it's getting colder
and colder and it starts to get
harder underneath the dirt gets harder
and some of those shorter cleats just
don't dig in they kind of stay right on
top of the
you know on the grass to where it just
rips the grass out instead of digging
into the soil a little bit
and yeah he was too long to make the
switch but finally did
and even though he didn't play the whole
second half i don't think i don't really
remember him slipping in the second half
once he made that change
we've all slipped on wet grass before
and it will get progressively wet over
the course of an evening
as dew settles in on right and there was
a moment in the first half where
jarvis landry fumbled and then somehow
recovered his own fumble and somebody
came over and it looked like someone was
trying to play golf with a shovel
that was the size of the divot that came
up out of the and you could see the
officials trying to
trying to replace it and pat it back
down that didn't give me a whole lot of
faith
in the quality of the well-manicured
field at cleveland i mean i
look it's okay to say there's a problem
with the field tonight sure but
what yeah and and that that's just what
kind of bothers me sometimes i feel like
there's an effort to carry water
we don't need to carry water we need to
call it like it is because we don't call
it like it is it's never going to get
any better and i'm still astounded chris
as are you that they don't spend
every penny dollar
dime necessary to ensure
the highest possible quality of every
playing surface for every nfl stadium it
shouldn't
be that difficult if they can do it in
wisconsin
yeah they should be able to do it
anywhere no you're right they should be
able to
and you know at least it's grass out
there last night yes it was not perfect
but also we got to take this to an
account too
like and correct me please if i'm wrong
here
i don't really see the i didn't see the
browns slipping in the first half
they must have been aware of what that
field
might become or what it is maybe the
soil is
a little softer than this awesome there
was some slipping not like lamar but
when making cuts they were slipping yeah
all right good but yeah obviously the
soil was soft and that's that's part of
being a football player and
so you got that's why you got to bring
extra cleats to games is just for those
things and you know the equipment guys
have it
usually but usually they tell you to
bring another pair of cleats or two of
pericles
just in case you need to change it for a
given surface on a given night or
weather or whatever it may be
there's a stubbornness to lamar jackson
which i think is one of his better
qualities but
i think it's hard for the organization
at times to pierce through it
and get him to do what he needs to do
for example maybe he needed an iv
earlier he clearly needed to change the
cleats earlier i just think there are
times where his attitude is
i'm fine yeah they need someone on that
sideline to say to him no you're not
put these damn shoes on now right and at
least they got through to him at
halftime all right let's take a break
and as you said
the bra and look look i understand that
brown's fans
are upset today but isn't this
better than what you're used to
this is different you're relevant you're
competing you're contending and the best
is yet to come
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports